you're forgotten in history bro that's
what you just did Bernie his greatest
contribution is gonna be a OC maybe
maybe and we'll see what happens whether
she seems to be Cesario she's a star but
she seems to be toned a party line right
she's not [ __ ] with the mozi girls
anymore right she used to be with them
the girl gang this that the other and
all of a sudden she's not talking
she's not talking about Biden being
senile she's not talking about the the
Democratic Party like she's real quiet
all of a sudden and I think they tapped
her they said hey listen you could have
a future than the party shut your
[ __ ] mouth
mm-hmm shut your [ __ ] mouth stop
going on Twitter stop yapping
stop going in front of Congress and
yappin and you know what the second you
give them the opportunity all sudden
they get real [ __ ] quiet how know he
is but I feel like that might be the
first female president come on bro you
know I think she a star
whether you while I don't know any of
her politics I don't I don't really call
it Rick so matter I just watch he's just
a star politics don't matter
intelligent doesn't matter none of these
things matter it's likability content I
think she's a star she's cute she's so
unlike wormdo she speaks well say again
I'm folk with her
yeah they hate that [ __ ] up and I'll
vote for cuz she Hindu so straight up
let's go me with you that's opposed and
easy OC man yeah Oh see that's people
look they're just like yeah I'm ready
Aoki let's go I don't think she's
likable you already said it was likable
people like her I think there was
something likable about Bernie to us cuz
we like don't give a [ __ ] most people
don't like don't give a [ __ ] we're
outliers aoc gives a [ __ ] she's cute she
says things that people care about she
caters well without sounding super
pantry to most people I don't
necessarily [ __ ] with it I'm also sexist
so you know hmm we got to be honest
about who we are in a certain point yeah
I don't know there's something about
aoc to me and it might be a political
thing but like she's kind of like
virtuous like gotcha
that's what every girl here now for sure
she's saying we'll see how Middle
America feels I don't I don't have any
idea I thought Trump was gonna get
crushed in 26
I'm obviously out of touch with what
middle America thinks yeah but I just
see a star when I see her that's it why
it's just it's just clear like when you
watch her you're just it she's got it
whatever the [ __ ] it is they always say
that and it sounds so corny but she's
got more charisma than pretty much every
politician outside of Trump Trump got
the most you can't deny I hate Trump or
like Trump this in [ __ ] you're
watching AOC is the same she's on screen
with other candidates you watching her
if she's on stage with [ __ ] booty
judge and cool guitar whatever the [ __ ]
Elizabeth Warren I'm watching AOC so and
she was a bartender yeah that's a
romantic story also she knows how to
talk to whatever in crowd comes in her
way and it's a story to that's a great
point after she knows I've talked to
everybody's a bartender but also it's a
story you know this is rags to riches in
our president the [ __ ] was a bartender
every other president comes from money
but rock didn't go outside of that they
all come from families money blah blah
blah etc she's a bartender there's like
romance today when she's a woman cute
when she talks my god this is where I go
I go when when Barack Obama talks I went
like this I went oh [ __ ] yeah yeah hey
that's true when George Bush talked I
went when Trump talks I go this bugger
is white like I smile yeah when they
talk dude FDR talk you're into it like
you go back to speeches Abraham Lincoln
I don't I don't never heard him speak so
I can't you know ever but but it's like
there is a [ __ ] likability of them
when a OC talks I literally I I look at
the screen and I go I hope one of the
legs on her chair breaks knowing to me
not just [ __ ] with Congress like so what
did you say
you're annoying I'm your grandmother
once what bought a bagel at a deli is
she supporting the oppressive regime
against Palestine like what do you [ __ ]
it's self-serving for sure but people
love that who
people who heap down loves that song
that's Trump know Trump is mad
self-serving every comment is I'm the
best
I do it every politician in self-service
know what we love about Trump is not
that what we love about Trump regardless
if you like or hate his politics what we
love about trunk is humor he's funny and
he denies whatever he says he owns it
he's an apology it's the same reason why
6:9 is gonna come back completely
unscathed oh my god I disagree with the
hundred percent hundred percent hundred
percent free stuff he's already doing
his comeback by the way six nine do you
see he was on Tory Lanez is live now and
he goes he goes he goes let me play my
new [ __ ] right now I'm a snitch on you
huh he's funny he's funny I think you
got man yes I'd say you're on the wrong
side with six nine minutes why cuz he's
a snitch I think that's you're acting
like I care it's not about sides I'm
just telling you what's going to happen
in my opinion what I believe is people
care more about humor than they care
about policy Trump's policies are
abhorrent to a lot of people but he's so
funny that people cannot stop watching
him I don't find a OC funny she's never
made me laugh once George Bush was funny
Barack Obama was funny
a oh she's not funny to me she's an
attractive woman for a politician she
might be the most attractive woman if
she was ugly people will be saying shut
your fat ass up I literally think the
only reason we listen to a OC is because
she's attractive and her politics align
with people I literally think the only
thing I don't think there's anything to
her outside of being a track every time
I said she was a star we listened to him
Kardashian and her opinions on black
people in jail I mean she got some out
say what cuz she got a few of them out
you know how many people have gotten
black people out of jail but this [ __ ]
got a fair D so all the sudden were like
no you got a good point yo you're right
but that's my point is she's cute every
time I say she's a star I say she's cute
that's one of the first things I name
you have not D first you
I thought you were going out your way to
see it one time you're really talking
like some wine can't wait to see the
comments run that [ __ ] back we go see
these gone I can't wait yo listen you
didn't say at one time you said this
year the it factor you said she's good
at talking and then you say he's
well-spoken that suit
she never says 100% since you never said
she cute once you're such a cute why
she's cute no no I know that's all we
care about now if she's not cute none of
it matters Leslie's saying you didn't
say that what do you mean hypothetically
speaking
you didn't say any of that let's just
say that hypothetically speaking you
didn't say that and all you said was
what you said which is she is a factor
Yeah right
the a factor if she's not cute I think I
would disagree with you and then say
that she's hot and that's the only
reason why people care because you
disagree with me saying she is
well-spoken she is intelligent she is
whatever no matter if she's ugly yeah
she's not ugly so that's why I think
she's a star because she's cute and got
the other [ __ ] if she has some cute
vapid [ __ ]
all right we're not voting for Kim
Kardashian I think we couldn't project
12 years but we're not gonna vote for
just a cute [ __ ] but she's cute and got
the other [ __ ] that's why I think she's
a star I don't know her policies that's
it that's why I think she got a chef
saber carpets will see this yeah and
then if it is true that you didn't say
she's cute not even once you probably
even talked about her look at all that
would you like to apologize I'll
apologize in the next episode and when
we find out that is cute when we find
out she is cute yeah you're gonna
apologize absolutely okay okay
[Applause]
I'm sorry that you said that [ __ ] like a
meek a little [ __ ] apology no save
[Applause]